Next up; if you're out there dating,
and I know you can relate to this,
I certainly can; getting ghosted is kinda the worst.
When someone goes poof! on you,
especially after you've been connecting,
that's when you go, okay, maybe it's ghosted,
but it should be called am I going crazy?
Exactly.
So you're wondering what the heck went wrong.
Our next guest went viral for trying to find out.
After a guy ghosted her, she sent him
a thorough questionnaire to get to the bottom of it.
Yes, she did!
I am so excited!
Shanna Falch, tell us, teach us!
Welcome, Shanna Falch!
Hi Shanna!
Thank you, hi everyone!
(audience cheers)
Thank you so much, thank you!
Thank you for coming on this show.
What inspired you to create
and send this exit interview to the guy who ghosted you?
So I recently changed jobs and in corporate America,
once you leave a job, you typically go
through an exit interview.
And not far after that happened, I got ghosted,
and I said, you know what?
Let's do something about this.
Let's call him out on his actions.
So I had gotten ghosted and we have that kind of comedy
back and forth that I thought it would be funny
to send him some funny questions,
but really just to call him out on his behavior
because it's not cool, it's really not cool.
And maybe learn something.
Correct, yeah.
What was your mental strategy going into this as well?
And what advice do you have for anyone
who might want to attempt this?
Yeah, so I went into it with an open mind,
knowing that, one, he may not respond,
and I already got my answer when he ghosted me.
So that was my first initial reaction.
I already got my answer when he stopped texting me.
I know my self-worth and my self-confidence
is better than that, so I knew I wasn't gonna get anything
out of it, if anything.
Yes!
(audience cheers)
Thank you!
I love that!
I'm curious, what kind of questions
did you put on the questionnaire?
How'd you start?
That's the good questions.
Just light-hearted questions.
One, really just being able for him
to be able to self-reflect on some things,
just calling him out.
One, how good looking am I?
Oh my god, you did not!
Rate my personality,
but they really weren't questions about me.
It was more for him to self-reflect on the actions that he-
What else? Give us the rest
of the questions.
Did you ask, like,
where'd you go?
(audience laughs)
Yes, yeah.
I did, I said, well, I asked why he ghosted me,
and really just the multiple choice questions
were just, hey, this is gonna be funny either way for me.
So yeah, so there are some funny questions in there,
but rating my personality, rating my looks,
which I don't care what he said either way.
And then, yeah, just, you know,
why he ghosted me, what happened.
So you sent these questions
and then we have to know, did he write back?
He did.
He did?!
(audience cheers)
Love it!
Tell me, what did he say?
Yeah, so he initially gave me great responses,
but the big thing was is things were moving
too fast for him.
The connection was really strong between us,
which is also why I kinda sent this to him.
What went wrong?
There was no defining moment as to why he ghosted me.
We weren't talking about anything specific when it happened.
So he was open to let me know
that it was just moving too fast for him
and that he was the one in the wrong, so.
I'm glad he took responsibility for it.
I think anybody that's ghosted somebody,
it usually it has to do with that person.
Like, they're not ready to be in a relationship
and at least he owned those feelings.
You know what, women, how is it for men?
Because women love closure.
Oh yeah.
It's like, I almost
don't care what the answer is,
I would just prefer the answer.
So how has everybody responded to this?
'Cause this has gone bananas,
it's viral, everybody's talking about it.
Like a million views on TikTok, thousands of responses.
What are people saying?
Yeah.
It just really kinda built a community
where people were open and honest about, hey,
this happened to me, really made me realize
that I wanna get back to dating in the real world.
I hate the apps, I'm over them.
There's just so much missed in the apps,
so I've been working on creating a social group
here in Nashville for singles just to meet out in public,
get back out into the world and get off the apps.
There's so much missed on the apps of personality,
and that can be pretty shallow at times,
so working on getting that started.
Shanna, I bet the company that lost you
is really bummed out right now.
You are so smart!
Yeah.
(audience applauds)
I bet the man that lost you is pretty bummed out too.
I know! You are like the biggest catch,
personally and professionally.
Do you mind if we circle back with you again?
I'd like to catch up with you again.
I would love that.
(upbeat music)